- I love this too, that
your latest single,
it's with your dad, right?
- [Noah] It is, yeah.
- [Kelly] And it's "Noah Stand Still."
- [Noah] It is.
- So, where does that come,
is it from him telling you to be still?
- Yeah, so I have stand
still here on my arm
and so does my dad.
I'm actually covering my pinky
because I have all of
these nails, but one, so-
- Oh, I've done that on this show!
- I'm just going like this
for the remainder of our...
- I've totally done that
with my ring finger one time
and I was like, "I'm gonna look like
I'm flashing gang signs."
I'm like, 'cause I was trying to hide it.
I didn't even notice, you're so good.
I was looking at your
cool tat so you're good.
- Oh, thank you.
So, no, stand still's just
been around through generations
on my dad's side.
His grandfather, his
dad, passed down to him
and has kind of shared that advice of,
when you don't know what
to do, just stand still.
I took a trip to see my dad,
I think around August, 2020,
which was a couple months before I really
committed to recovery,
and we stood up on his hill in Nashville,
and Nashville's just
such a peaceful place.
- Beautiful, too, yeah.
- And he had me take my shoes off
and put my feet in the grass
and really get connected to home.
And he said, "Now we just stand still.
Like, breathe in the
air, just stand still,
and get connected back
to who you really are."
Like, you know, "None of
the rest of this matters.
Like, let's just be here, me and you."
And we had such an amazing moment
that I hadn't had in such a long time
and he has no idea,
well, I mean, he will now
'cause he's watching this at home.
Hi, Dad.
But he really had no
idea, I think at the time.
- [Kelly] The impact.
- I think, as parents,
you can see your child is struggling,
but he didn't know really
how much I really needed
to hear that and be reminded
of that at that time.
- That's so cool that you're able to like
have that in your family.
Y'all are musical and you have that gift
to be able to share together,
that's really special.
I challenge everyone to find
something that's just artistic
'cause it comes out in a different way
and it's a good release, I think.